this is desperation be under no doubt
about it
the disaster caused by this catastrophic
event is far from over
there's very little aid relief getting
through when it does chaos can be
moments away
the relief truck is overwhelmed they
scramble on board grabbing what they can
find
many have lost everything and families
will have anything
the streets of towns along the swat
river are filled with people growing
increasingly desperate
the army and police are here to keep
order but imposing that order will get
harder as the days pass
it's been a real changing atmosphere
here in the last few days
i think people were very shell-shocked
at the beginning but now actually they
seem to be getting angry about the lack
of aid that's getting to them
of course many of the villages that
they're coming from completely cut off
so it's it's really desperate as each
day goes by we're getting more and more
angry
bahrain is a major town it's been split
in half by the flood but there is food
here beyond there are more than 200 000
people who remain cut off in the
mountains
through the battered town thousands make
their way with whatever they can carry
strapped to their backs
it starts at this rickety bridge
streaming across for the start of a
dangerous trek to find their families
they've walked six to nine hours to get
here and they will walk back again
they are all exhausted already but they
have no choice but to make the journey
khalid with lentils flour and oil is on
his way back to his wife children mother
and father they're all waiting for him
he says it's a tough climb to get there
but he has simply no choice
helicopter drops can't feed 200 000
people it's as simple as that and they
know this
the point is these people have simply
given up waiting they've come long
distances and now that they've got
whatever provisions they could get
they're gonna head back home it's about
35 kilometers away incredibly over those
mountains
the flood has now severed the only road
out of bahrain the river shifted its
position
the locals crisscrossed the torrent on
rickety bridges and even more perilous
cable trolleys
we met shamshire in the remains of her
home she is 105 years old
like so many here she believes the
changing weather
her centenarian husband cherry gull
agrees with his
[Music]
i wouldn't give wife no revenue
amid the destruction families adapt to
the new shape of their town
washing in the midst of the newly
arrived boulders
but the real priority here is to
redirect the river and to start building
bridges and repairing roads heading
north everything beyond this point is
destroyed
people have scattered from that side
because no lanka or
bridges or all languages are washed away
by the flood but the alhamdulillah local
people are helped each other a little
bit
but the relief is not enough for us we
need
a lot of
foods items medicines and such more
items for home shelters etc that that
will be a little bit good for us
neither faith or resolve can be doubted
in pakistan
but this is simply overwhelming and they
desperately need help
stuart ramsey sky news bahrain in the
swap valley